one of the most disruptive web
technologies in recent years is without
a doubt tailwind css it defies the
long-standing dogma of semantic css and
instead preaches a more functional
utility-class approach like many i found
it offensive at first glance but the
reality is that it can produce beautiful
and customizable uis faster than any
other approach i've tried nobody pays me
to say that i'm just obsessed with
things that are pragmatic that can get
your app shipped faster in today's
beginner friendly tutorial you'll learn
everything you need to know to design a
website with tailwind you guys request a
weak loan discord so we'll build a
discord inspired dashboard we'll focus
on the most interesting part of the ui
which is the sidebar that has these
animated icon buttons that show a
tooltip when hovered we'll also throw in
dark mode and i'll explain how to
integrate tailwind with any
component-based javascript library but
first there's a red button that says
subscribe below this video most hiring
managers in the tech industry recommend
that you click the button before we jump
into the code let's answer the question
of what is tailwind and should i use it
basically it's just a huge collection of
css utility classes compared to plain
css it allows you to write less code
overall and have standards that prevent
you from blowing your foot off however
tailwind does not provide pre-built
components like bootstrap this means it
will likely take you longer to build a
ui than bootstrap but it gives you much
better control over customization some
people say tailwind is not for beginners
but i've kind of changed my mind here
the tooling has become really
exceptional and when you hover over a
class in vs code it tells you exactly
what css is inside it's kind of like css
with training wheels and will do things
like dead code elimination so you're not
left with a massive css file when you go
to production ultimately though tailwind
is for developers who want to get highly
customized stuff done faster to follow
along with this project open up your
editor and then pull up a terminal
session and i've installed the tailwind
extension for vs code the first thing
we'll want to do is generate a project
with a javascript framework like react
view angular svelte etc one of the major
reasons tailwind is so popular is
because it works really well with
component-based javascript libraries i'm
going to use react for this demo but the
same principles apply to any other
framework and you'll find setup
instructions for all the major
frameworks in the official tailwind docs
for this demo i've created a new project
with create react app to add tailwind to
it we need to install our dependencies
then install a package called cracko to
override the native post css
configuration use it to replace react
scripts in the package json then create
a cracko config file to apply the
tailwind plugin from there we can use
npx to run the tailwind cli and nic
command which will generate a tailwind
config in the root of the project and
finally we go into our index.css file
and use the tailwind directive to
include the actual tailwind styles in
our project run npm start to run the
project locally that was kind of a lot
of work to set up but i think by the end
of the video you'll see that it was well
worth it let's first open up the
tailwind config file this file is used
to customize the behavior of tailwind
you can use it to customize colors add
plugins and a bunch of other things one
change i'm going to make right away is
to enable just in time mode as of today
this feature is in developer preview but
it will compile your css on the fly
making your build times much much faster
the other thing we can do is tell
tailwind to purge any unused css from
our final bundle it's not really
relevant to this video but if we were
deploying to production it would allow
us to ship a very small css file to the
browser now let's go ahead and open up a
react component in the project you'll
notice that when i add a css class to it
we get this awesome intellisense with
every single tailwind utility available
to us the whole idea behind tailwind is
that you add these utilities together to
design your ui directly in the html for
example let's go ahead and take a
paragraph element and apply the text
center class to it you'll notice that if
you hover over this utility class it
will tell you the actual css used under
the hood if we want to add a color to it
we might say text green and it will give
us a palette of different green colors
to choose from there's a utility for
pretty much anything you can imagine
doing and they're very carefully named
just type out what you're trying to do
like bold and there's likely a utility
class to get the job done now if we go
ahead and view this code in the browser
you can see we have some green text in
the middle of the screen now that you
know the basics it's time to build out
an interactive and animated ui you can
find the full source code on github and
it contains a more complete dashboard
implemented with tailwind what we're
going to focus on here is the sidebar
and the first thing we'll need is a
flexible container to wrap the entire ui
the thing i love about tailwind is that
i don't really need to think of a class
name in order to do that i can just come
in here to the root div in the app
component and give it a class name of
flex which will apply the css display
flex property to it that's easy enough
when you have one class to apply but
things get much harder to maintain when
you have dozens of classes to apply to
an element the best way to keep your ui
organized is to break it down into
smaller components which we can do by
creating a new file like sidebar.js and
then export a functional component from
it called sidebar once that's done we
can then import that component from our
main app component and declare it inside
of the flex container now back in the
sidebar i'll return some jsx from it
which contains a div and a bunch of
icons that for now will just have text
as placeholders now we can use tailwind
to position the container for the
sidebar it should be fixed to the top
left corner of the screen so naturally
we use the fixed utility class to do
that now to position it at the top we
use top dash 0. that applies the top
property with a value of 0 pixels you'll
notice intellisense provides a bunch of
different values for the top property
but sometimes you might need to throw a
weird value in there so you can use
brackets followed by the pixels that you
want to use and tailwind will
automatically create a utility class for
you we don't need to do that here but it
is a cool trick to know if you want to
break out of your design system we also
have a utility for the left property but
when it comes to the height we want to
use a responsive value where it's 100
percent of the view height the utility
for that is h dash screen which means it
will take up the entire height of the
screen now to apply the width we'll use
a value of w-16 you might intuitively
think this means 16 pixels but it
actually means 16 units on tailwind
spacing scale it's designed to provide
you with a set of constraints that make
your spacing look good and consistent
between elements in this case w16 means
for rem or 64 pixels other utilities
like m and p for margin and padding
respectively follow the same spacing
scale that's all the code we need to
position the sidebar now we'll add flex
and flex column to position the elements
inside of it and finally we'll give it a
background using bg dash color and
tailwind has a huge color palette with
nine different shades for each color
built into the framework when a color
starts with bg it will be applied as the
css background property and when it
starts with text it will be applied as
the color property and as a final touch
let's add a shadow to make the ui look a
little more polished you could easily
spend hours fine-tuning a shadow but
tailwind makes it super easy with a
bunch of built-in shadows that look
really nice out of the box the end
result should be a basic dark container
for the sidebar the only problem though
is that the current shade of gray
doesn't really match up with discord's
branding so let's take a look at how we
can customize the color palette open up
the tailwind config file and find the
theme object inside of it one thing we
might want to do is extend the theme
with our own custom color types like
primary and secondary by doing that
tailwind will give us our own unique set
of utility classes based on these colors
for example we could replace our other
colors with bg primary or text secondary
however it's worth noting that tailwind
ships with a bunch of other color
palettes that we might want to use if we
import tailwind colors we can then set
our gray colors to something else like
blue gray or warm gray but in this demo
i want our colors to look exactly like
discord so i reverse engineered them
from the discord app and i'm going to
use those colors to replace the tailwind
defaults like so the change is subtle
but our colors now match discord exactly
and now we can switch gears to the
animated icon buttons and tool tips in
the nav bar the first thing i'll do is
create a new react component called
sidebar icon it takes an icon component
as an input prop and just renders out a
div with a class of sidebar icon with
the icon itself inside of it there's a
cool package called react icons that
allows us to import a bunch of different
icons from libraries like font awesome
and bootstrap as react components we can
then declare our sidebar icon component
and pass in an icon component as a prop
you should now be able to see these
icons in the sidebar but now here's
where things get a little more
interesting when it comes to tailwind
instead of using a utility class here
we're using our own custom class called
sidebar icon but this class is actually
built up using tailwind utilities this
is totally optional but in some cases it
makes more sense to create your own
custom class with tailwind as opposed to
extracting out your own custom react
component if we want to add additional
classes or components to tailwind we can
go into the index css file and use the
layer directive to extend the core
components from here we can define our
own custom classes just like we would in
regular css but instead of properties
and values we'll use the apply directive
and combine a bunch of tailwind
utilities together we'll give an icon
relative positioning make it a flex
container and center the content in the
middle the element needs to be a square
so we'll provide a height and width of
12. when it comes to margins you can
target individual properties like top or
bottom using mt or mb but if they have
the same value you can be even more
efficient by using mx or my to take care
of both of them at the same time that
takes care of the positioning for the
icons now let's go ahead and give each
icon a gray background and a text color
of green but now you might be wondering
how do we change these colors when we
hover over an icon tailwind provides
variants for css pseudo classes by
simply prefixing existing classes with
hover focus and things like that it's
also worth noting that there are
variants like medium and large to
conditionally apply classes based on the
size of the viewport when building
responsive layouts now in the demo the
color of each icon should change when
you hover over it however on discord
you'll notice that when you hover over
an icon it has this nice little
animation that goes from a circle to a
square with rounded corners so how do
animations work in taiwan well the first
thing we'll need are some properties
that change in this case we're already
changing the colors on hover but we're
also going to change the border radius
it's triple xl by default which will
create a circle and then goes to excel
on hover we can then animate between
these two states using transition all
which will create a css transition with
some default settings we can override
the defaults like duration or easing
with additional utility classes and we
now have these cool animated icons with
a very minimal css footprint in our code
but now let's take things a step further
by adding an animated tool tip to each
icon to make that possible we'll first
need to go back to our sidebar icon
component i'm going to add a default
prop for text and then a span with a
class of sidebar tooltip that displays
that text then back in the css let's go
ahead and build out that class once
again using the apply directive we'll
add a bunch of classes here that i'm not
going to explain again that will produce
a ui where all of the tooltips are
currently visible the challenge though
is that we want these elements to be
invisible by default and only shown when
the user hovers over the parent element
making the tooltip invisible is easy in
this case we'll give it a scale of 0 to
accomplish that but how do we change the
scale when hovered we can't use hover
here because it's impossible for the
user to hover over an invisible element
in tailwind we can apply classes to a
child element when the parent is hovered
using groups a group is a clever way to
apply classes to a child when the state
of its parent changes however one
important caveat to be aware of is that
groups don't work properly and apply not
a big deal we can go back to our markup
and use the classes there it's a really
simple process use the group utility on
the parent class then change the
appearance of the child using variants
like group hover followed in this case
by scale 100 the end result is a tool
tip hidden by default that animates into
view when the parent element is hovered
at this point our demo is looking pretty
good but it's missing one important
thing dark mode tailwind makes dark mode
really easy to implement but we first
need to opt into it in the config file
there are two ways to go about it with
media tailwind will look for the prefers
color scheme property in css and if it's
dark it will apply any classes that have
that dark variant in front of it that's
pretty simple but not ideal for every
site another option is class that will
look on parent elements for a dark class
and when it's present use the dark
variant for any of its children that's
the strategy we use in this demo and
there's a custom react hook in the full
source code to manage the user's
preference in local storage from there
the implementation of dark mode is
simply a matter of going into your
elements and using the dark variant to
define the colors that you want to
activate when dark mode is enabled
congratulations that's pretty much
everything you need to know to start
being super productive with tailwind if
you found this video helpful make sure
to hit the like button and subscribe and
if you're ready for more advanced
content consider becoming a pro member
at fireshipio thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one